our tail of the tape for this
lightweight championship fight both of
our fighters are 27. penis is three
inches taller he will have a three inch
reach advantage
and once again here's bruce paul
ladies and gentlemen
this is
the main event of the evening
and the referee in charge of the octagon
this
is the moment usc fans
have been waiting for
live
from the mgm grand garden arena in las
for
vegas
undisputed
ufc
lightweight
championship
of the world
introducing first the challenger
fighting out of the blue corner
this man is a jiu jitsu fighter holding
a professional record of 24 wins
one loss he stands five feet seven
inches tall weighing in at 155
jose
all down
the champion
fighting out of the red card
this man is a taekwondo fighter only a
professional
17 wins two losses he stands five feet
10 inches tall bring
out of milwaukee wisconsin usa
presenting
the reigning defending
undisputed
ufc
lightweight
champion of the world
anthony
you have seatbelts online guys attack
yourself at all time will win my command
on all time if you want to touch love do
it now go back to your corner
jose aldo is one of the most explosive
and dangerous fighters to ever compete
in the ufc he's capable of ending a
fight on a split second with fantastic
flying knees kicks punches and elbows
and if it goes to the ground he is
absolutely world class at brazilian jiu
jitsu
although counters with
nice escape and he's up to his feet
although with the block nice defense
oh
look at this who saw that coming big
left
what an exchange
battle
nice late kick by pettis and he connects
here
he lands a big right hand
he connects with the punch
under two minutes now
pettis with the one two that scored
nice perry there
aldo was a good kick
oh solid jab
pettis with the combination
nope can't get it again
joe perfect technique on the block of
that huge head kick oh it's a powerful
elbow
pancake
he did a nice job blocking the head kick
good side kick to the bottom
oh great combination
nice takedown
he's controlling his posture keeps him
from sitting up
big shot
perez's
joe that cut is looking worse
anthony pettis is bleeding from his nose